all cryptocurrencies are going to zero
not Bitcoin and probably not ethereum
and probably not some stable coins just
because of how back they are by Major
institutions but the rest are going to
zero your favorite shitcoin yet it's
going to zero they're just projects with
no utility what you want to do is you
want to make your money in shitcoins
that's absolutely fine but you've got to
get out and also don't get emotionally
attached to them do not get greedy that
is where everybody messes up as soon as
you have the money and you're in the
green and you have the profits get out
move your profits into something like
Bitcoin or even stable coins but that is
where everybody goes wrong and they ride
those shitcoins all the way down to zer